[ZH] 以外也是比較可能是有增強的成功
[ZH] 這個元素都顯示了就是在我們的這個計劃裡面呢
[ZH] 我們必須要非常深刻的去了解這個青少年
[ZH] 那有了這個臨床輪的幫助的話
[ZH] 我們更可以做到這一個
[ZH] 那一個治療一個信任的這個臨床人員關係
[ZH] 可以幫助青少年感覺到自己被理解
[ZH] 而且是被關懷著
[ZH] 那這些想法都是互相互補的
[ZH] 那一起的話可以創造出一個非常好
[ZH] 而且可以持續下去的改變
[ZH] 謝謝大家
[ZH] 好
[ZH] 早上有總共四位講者分享了非常精彩的題目
[ZH] 那接下來我們有一個綜合討論的時間
[ZH] 那剛剛大家上傳的這個提問
[ZH] 我們已經有幻樹的整理
[ZH] 稍後我們可能會請不同的講者
[ZH] 按照大家的提問
[ZH] 給出一些比較明確的回覆
[ZH] 那當然有一些提問
[ZH] 它可能比較偏向是某一些個案的分析
[ZH] 那像這樣的型別的部分
[ZH] 我們早上暫時不會提出來討論
[ZH] 因為這裡有一些比較通則性的問題
[ZH] 是希望可以為各位其他的這個
[ZH] 我們講說學員帶來更多的對於準則
[ZH] 還有早上這一些我們講說學習的這些內容
[ZH] 有更多明確的一些釐清
[ZH] 那接下來我們是不是邀請
[ZH] Overallis Faker
[ZH] 好 接下來我可能會請翻譯
[ZH] 把大家的提問單各自
[ZH] 依照你們想要提問的物件
[ZH] 然後分享
[ZH] 然後提問我們的專家
[ZH] 然後由他們來個別回答
[ZH] 第一問是你,Berry。其實,這兩位問是,第一問是,教育學生,如何準備好自己的學生,如何準備好自己的學生,或是有自殺的想法?第二,如何社會或社會的社會可以在這種生活教育教練?
[ZH] 那我, sorry, I can translate.
[ZH] 那這邊提問的問題是給Berry回答的
[ZH] 第一個是學校教育端來說的話
[ZH] 是怎麼樣可以幫助學生是已經有就是心理障礙
[ZH] 或是說甚至有自殺意念要怎麼幫助他們
[ZH] 那第二個是我們講到就是lifescale coach這個概念
[ZH] 那社會或是社群是可以如何扮演這個角色
[ZH] 請問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問問
[EN]  And to have a classroom full of 30 or 40 students and at the same time pay attention to the one who's challenged is extremely difficult because your priority is to teach and educate.
[EN]  To manage behavior takes all of your resources and sometimes it eclipses teaching.
[EN]  However, there is a saying that I grew up with in the UK, an ounce of prevention is better than a pound of cure.
[ZH]  however there is a saying that I grew up with in the UK, an ounce of prevention is better than a pound of cure.
[ZH] 但是英國有一句話,中文也有治療,方範勝於治療
[ZH] 所以我相信有些事情可以做在學校的地方 去幫助事情走正好。
[ZH] 我只是想解釋一下兩個簡單的技巧, 簡單要做,但你必須要與他們的意志。
[ZH] 如果你做的, 它可以改變成效果。
[ZH] 我相信可以在教室裡做出一些事情來確保,而是讓事情可能會有比較好的發展
[ZH] 這邊有兩個技能
[ZH] 第一個技能叫做預測
[ZH] so if I was in a classroom with 30 students and two of them misbehaved
[ZH] 比如說我現在有30個學生的班,然後有兩個同學比較不守秩序
[ZH] before I started instructing, I would pull those two students aside before the classroom started
[ZH] and I would relay what my expectations are
[ZH] 那在我開始教課前,我可能就會把這兩位同學先帶到旁邊去,然後做出一些相應的措施。
[ZH] I would do it in a warm, relational way, I would set a goal, and then at the end of the classroom period, I would give both students brief feedback.
[ZH] 那我會試著要跟他們建立一個比較長期的關係
[ZH] 然後我會給他們設立清楚的目標
[ZH] 那在這場課結束以後
[ZH] 我也會給他們再次的一個回饋
[ZH] The second skill is tied to the first
[ZH] You have to recognize the positive gains that a student makes
[ZH] Even if they're so small
[ZH] You have to recognize the positive
[ZH] So for every piece of constructive feedback you gave a student
[ZH]  you'd want to give him at least two positives
[ZH]  so he feels like he is making a difference
[ZH]  and once that student has received positive feedback
[ZH]  it will help him gain momentum
[ZH]  now sometimes you have to search for the feedback
[ZH]  sometimes you have to look really hard
[ZH]  but what you're going to see
[ZH]  is as you focus on the positive
[ZH]  you're going to reinforce it and see more of it
[ZH] 就是試著在給他們的回饋當中至少有兩個點是正向的
[ZH] 就是雖然有時候對老師來說有點難找到
[ZH] 但是還是要努力的找
[ZH] 就是因為他們有了正向的回饋
[ZH] 其實就會更有動力去把事情做好
[ZH] Forecasting and looking for the positive
[ZH] doesn't guarantee an outcome
[ZH] but over time if you're intentional
[ZH] it will move the needle in the right direction
[ZH] 那就是我剛剛講到的預測以及正向回饋這兩個
[ZH] 我相信如果辭職也很擁實踐的話
[ZH] 應該可以讓事情慢慢走在對的方向
[ZH] 第二個問題是
[ZH] How society or communities play a role in this kind of life-scale culture concept
[ZH] This is where it is really challenging
[ZH] I just spoke with Tiffany
[ZH] 前一段時間後,我給了我的課程
[ZH] 這個問題提得很好,同時也是反映出我們現在面對的挑戰
[ZH] 我在演講完後,我跟Tiffany稍微聊了一下
[ZH] 她兒子是在患性上,患性上、患性上
[ZH] 她的兒子有患性上、患性上、患性上的責任
[ZH] 那他的兒子有ADHD,然後在生活上面也跟基本的一些責任是有困境的。
[ZH] 我們都知道現實生活中其實是很殘忍的,就是通常沒有辦法完全接納這樣的孩子。
[ZH] 但是身為大型的機構我們還是需要去接納
[ZH] 但是我講大型機構可能只佔了這個世界的20%
[ZH] 80% of the equation is on Tiffany's son
[ZH] 他需要健康生活教育,不一天,至少四或五次,這會花錢。
[ZH] 公共和公共和公共共同行業可能不可以給予這些服務,像公共共同行業。
[ZH] 其實這些計劃是很貴的。
[ZH] 在美國的話,其實大部分有需求的孩子會窮助於私人機構
[ZH] 私人機構比較像是在處理這一塊,在美國的話大部分是這樣的狀況
[ZH] 他的意思是,他們這一些費用是從醫療,私人醫療去付,所以你自己要在美國要買私人醫療保險,那私人的醫療保險會去附診,因為他剛剛跟我講一個月要入安期保險,將近五、六、十萬。
[ZH] You mean financially, right?
[ZH] 他那個是私的醫療系, sorry.
[ZH] 因為他喜歡買保險,但我印象我們有權利一件,他就是你自己買保險,他保險後就要保險資料。
[ZH] I grew up in the UK, where the medical world is dominated by the public sector.
[ZH] Barry他是在英國長大的,但在英國情況下大部分的醫療機構大家都會去比較公立的醫院去看醫生。
[ZH] 那在美國的話就是大部分的醫療支出的話是要大家去私人的醫院去做診癒
[ZH] The truth is, one is not significantly better than the other, both have positives and both have negatives
[ZH] 那也不能說哪一個形態比較好,其實都各有優缺點
[ZH] 但是私人醫療機構有一個優點就是競爭,競爭會推動進步
[ZH] 那有的競爭的話,其實機構就會互相去獨立,然後去進步,還有創新
[ZH] 謝謝
[ZH] 那下一個問題是給Drew
[ZH]  so the next question is to Drew
[ZH]  how to help an ADHD kid cope
[ZH]  when he feels he's constantly being shut down
[ZH]  by classmates and even family
[ZH]  when he interrupts conversations and teachers
[ZH]  with his random ideas in coherent logic
[ZH]  and thus use self-depreciating
[ZH]  self-sabotaging behavior
[ZH] 如果當一個患有過中症的孩子,他的想法叫天馬行空,然後邏輯不連貫,然後他會忍不住打斷對話,或是打斷老師的話,那因為這樣子總是感覺被同學或是家人打壓,制止,然後進了他就會開始自我貶低,擺爛,自我毀滅,來保護他脆弱受傷的內心,要怎麼樣協助他應對?
[ZH] 對,我覺得ADHD的海長會面臨這樣的碰境,
[ZH] 然後跟別人交情接觸,其實不管是老師,